au départ les fleurs de pissenlit sont
jaunes mais ça ne dure que quelque jours
très vite elle se transforme et
finissent par ressembler à une boule de
coton extrêmement fragile
en fait la tige de pissenlit ne porte
pas une fleur mais une multitude de
fleurons qui produit chacun une graine
alors évidemment le grand jeu c'est de
souffler chaque green est suspendu à une
touche de poils une aigrette des
chercheurs d'edimbourg au royaume uni
ont récemment découvertes grâce à sa
forme particulière et son nombre de
poils toujours le même un tourbillon se
forment au dessus de les grecs une
dépression qui va ralentir
considérablement la chute de la graine
de cette manière transportées par le
vent elle peut parcourir jusqu'à tenez
vous bien une centaine de kilomètres une
vraie capsule 2d confiné allez on
recommence bye bye
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents en cliquant
sur l'algue auchan réalise une nouvelle
chaque jour et pour être sûr de ne
louper aucune et bien abonnez vous et
activer la cloche aller à demain et
n'oubliez pas
nous sommes toujours confiné et en
restant bien